okay  i'll match it we good all good  let's go so bare hands only right no  pulling any mono wires or mantis blades  out of your ass  right  i asked cause the last guy i fought  tried to surprise me  so  [Music]  first anyway you ready to start  yep ready to rumble careful now  i don't [ __ ] around  check  [Music]  uh  oh  oh  uh  um  um  uh  hmm  ugh  um  um  ugh  [Music]  hmm  um think you had enough  [Music]  buffet  [Music]  i asked cause the last guy i fought  tried to surprise me with long spurs  anyway you ready to start  yep ready to rumble careful now  i don't [ __ ] around  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  uh  hmm  hmm  um  uh  um  uh  hmm  hmm  uh  cheers  um  uh  uh  i'm sorry [ __ ]  not another word hand over the stupid  keys and let's go home  here spoiler for me  what's your doom biz i got rubber to  burn